Marcus we interviewed you in 2015 I
believe
holy crap really I know it's been a
little bit yeah it's a long time it's
fun it was a great time it was in
Ventura at a theater yes you know yes
your your interviews have many many
views many many comments really
some of them positive some of them not
so positive and I have a question I was
wondering if you could address and that
is some of the people felt that you were
able to get a film made or sell a script
because you had previous connections and
can we dispel that myth oh oh yeah
totally
I'm completely locked in because I was
on a show a long time ago so I know all
the studio executives and I know all the
producers and I know all the investors
and they just give me money all the time
so it's super easy and you just meet
them you go to Dan town all the time
like Marcus we're trying to make this
film would you like 30 million dollars
we're gonna distribute it through Warner
Brothers and I'm like yeah great sounds
awesome
Kevin total done for people that don't
live in LA because LA I'm lying
oh yes I know I can tell sarcastically I
guess but some people don't realize that
like they think that you could be a
bartender where Hollywood screenwriters
or producers are and that you can just
get someone's friend a script and that's
not really how it works here
well here's the thing like yeah that's
possible like it's all possible you know
I have a friend who was PA and he was
working on a studio lot and a very very
very very very big movie star was
shooting a movie on that lot so
everybody was super excited about it and
my friend the PA was like god I've
written this script and this movie stars
perfect for it how do I find movie star
so they couldn't find him like he was
always not around so they figured out
which car was his and the PA put his
script on the movie stars windshield and
the movie star took the script and my
friend ended up being represented by the
movie stars agent so yeah all kinds of
stuff can happen it doesn't mean that
that's going to happen it doesn't mean
that it's like you're set in stone
trust me I mean I'm flattered that folks
think that I was that big of a deal on
Doogie Howser I was not I was I was like
the lowest guy on the totem pole I
didn't have extra connections I was
working in an industry I was doing my
best to pay attention to things I had an
agent that had no interest in my scripts
I think I told the story the last time
we talked I had a friend who was an
actor he had a friend who was a manager
I did not know the manager I had written
the script my friend was like you should
meet my friend the manager that's how it
happened it wasn't like I mean I guess
if if if the concern is you had an
advantage because you had a friend yeah
I did would I had that friend if I lived
in Kentucky probably not you know what I
mean but that doesn't mean that if
you're in Kentucky you can't blow up in
the film industry because that happens a
lot to like people into contests or they
submit their scripts to the Sundance lab
or whatever it is and they're in
Wisconsin or they're in Idaho or there
wherever and somebody sees that script
they don't have any connections they
just have a great script and people go
we're gonna fly you out to
Sun Dance and you're gonna sit here and
we're gonna help you develop then the
film gets made then they blow up and
they're sitting on the dice and then
they're making other films and they're
way past me yeah you know what I mean so
you know yeah everybody has advantages
or disadvantages one way or another but
you know I buy for the record it's not
like I was connected in that sense would
you say to even if someone is on this
like trajectory of like film after film
after film even for that level that it
can still be like starting from scratch
again for something that that person
wants to do if they want to do it the
Scriptures the industry has a very short
attention span and a long memory so if
they remember you well at a high enough
level there's a lot of stuff you can try
and you can do again I like to talk
about people like Danny DeVito Kevin
James everybody looks these guys as
leading men and they are but they didn't
start there Danny DeVito was doing
off-broadway plays play an adult like
literally like on his hands and knees
barking but he continued to grow and got
to such a point where people loved his
work that he became a leading man
same thing with Kevin James not that he
was barking onstage but you know he was
a stand-up comedian he was getting roles
and stuff the stand-up career got him
the show he was the leading man in the
show then he starts being a leading man
and and felt so you know you start where
you are and you grow from there but I
think that if Kevin James had started
off with his first project I was like
I'm not doing this unless I'm the
leading man I don't I don't necessarily
think that that would have fall you know
I think you build a repertoire
we'll just go with you people like you
they'll follow you anywhere look at Will
Smith Will Smith was a sitcom star right
but people love the show and they loved
him and he was like I want to become a
serious actor and everybody went okay
and they show up for his movies you know
it's like that's the thing like it's not
advantages/disadvantages everybody's got
them everybody's got both but it doesn't
mean that what you want is impossible
you know
you hunker down and focus on it none of
these people are different from anybody
else they're all humans they just put
their minds in a certain space and we're
like this is what I want
I deserve it nothing's gonna stop me
that's all really anybody has to do and
I know that sounds you know hippie
dippie or whatever but that's all
anybody did you know they got punched in
the face and they got punched in the
face and they got doors slam Donnell and
they're like okay there's another door
I'm gonna go over here now you know they
didn't necessarily get on Twitter and
complain about the doors get slammed on
him they just you know just keep going
that's all you can do in my opinion I
could be wrong but that's what I think
you